bonjour françois bayrou merci d'être
avec nous bien sûr en direct de pau
confinement oblige vous êtes maire de
pau vous êtes président du modem d'abord
un mot sur les chiffres les chiffres qui
continuent à être terrible jour après
jour des records 3500 morts depuis le
début de l'épidémie 499 en 24 heures les
français se préparent de plus en plus à
l'idée que ce confinement il dure
peut-être au-delà du 15 avril annoncée
est ce que c'est aussi ce que vous jugez
le plus sage
je pense qu'il est il serait très
imprudent de faire des pronostics à
court terme
optimiste je ne suis pas certain que
dans deux semaines les raisons qui ont
conduit au confinement serait me serait
finie je pense au contraire que tout ce
qu'on voit dans les chiffres et dans la
dynamique des chiffres conduit à penser
que probablement les pouvoirs publics
seront amenés à prolonger ce délai la et
donc tout le monde s'y prépare y a pas
un français qui croient que tout ça va
se lever à l'instant je pense au
contraire que ce qu'on voit c'est la
nécessité d'avoir des disciplines
d'avoir été conduite prudente d'avoir
tous ces gestes et toutes ces attitudes
qui font que la propagation du virus
sera ralentie à la fois pour que les
hôpitaux ne soit pas encombrer pour qu
on attende
j'espère que ça viendra un jour
traitements et vaccins
on va y revenir d'ailleurs sur cette
sortie et les modalités de sortie
ensuite de ce confinement mais d'abord
un mot sur les inégalités que ça révèle
que ça réveille peut-être ce qu'ils
peuvent
télétravail et la plupart du temps des
cadres ceux qui sont obligés de se
rendre au travail souvent les plus
modestes qui prennent donc le risque de
la contagion
on a quand même un peu le sentiment que
ces deux france qui ne sont pas
forcément traités à la même enseigne
comment est ce que vous voyez ce risque
éventuel d'explosions et dîner des
inégalités
je pense que tout le monde a conscience
que chacun où qu'il se trouve à des
responsabilités et des devoirs
alors il est vrai que ceux qui sont dans
le travail manuel dans les interventions
je pense aux équipes qui sont les
équipes de des communes des départements
et des régions ce qui font que les
autres peuvent vivre
on peut évidemment des responsabilités
particulières on a organisé des équipes
qui se relaient et puis il y aura je le
pense aussi des des gestes à faire pour
montrer que on tient compte
meseret il ya des différences y est
c'est pas la même chose
oui des gestes financiers je voulais
dire des primes
c'est vrai que c'est pas la même vinyle
même confinement lorsque vous avez une
maison et un jardin même petit et
lorsque vous avez un petit appartement
pour une famille nombreuse et c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue là les tensions
augmentent
les tensions à l'intérieur des couples
les tensions avec les enfants il ya même
parfois une augmentation des violences
c'est vrai c'est pas la même vie et
c'est pourquoi faut être très attentif à
la manière dont on régule le confinement
selon les quartiers et selon les
les espaces de vie où l'on nous on est
non source l'aéro vous parliez à
l'instant de gestes éventuel le
gouvernement a mis en place un certain
nombre de systèmes notamment pour les
entreprises mais de manière plus
immédiate quand on parle comme vous le
faisiez à l'instant de ceux qui doivent
aller travailler on pense bien sûr aux
manutentionnaires aux caissières à tous
ceux qui sont dans la logistique
transport qui assure aujourd'hui la
chaîne alimentaire également est-ce
qu'il faut systématiser les prix mais ce
qu'il faut que le gouvernement y
contraignent les entreprises quelle est
votre position
donc je crois que c'est un devoir que
les entreprises exercent au nom de la
collectivité que les collectivités
locales elles mêmes doivent exercer il
ya c'est un moment qui est très dur et
dans ce moment très dur il faut au
minimum qui est des gestes de
reconnaissance
il faut au minimum qu'on comprenne que
ceux qui assument ce travail qui est
souvent un travail manuel un travail de
de proximité bah ils ont droit à ce
qu'on leur donne un coup de pouce
quelque chose qui leur permettent de
reconnaître que leur travail a été
repéré a été vu et qu'on leur rend
hommage trouve que c'est une solidarité
nécessaire le gouvernement vient de
faire des gestes très important
permettant que là
la prime qui porte le nom du président
de la république depuis l'an dernier
soit versée sans charge sans difficulté
supplémentaire pour un certain nombre
d'entreprises je crois que ça doit être
aussi le cas des collectivités locales
les collectivités locales vous vous êtes
maire de pau est ce que ça veut dire que
vous pourriez montrer l'exemple et versé
verser cette prime on qu'on appelle
prime macron donc la prime défiscalisées
c'est exactement ce à quoi nous
travaillons avec les organisations
syndicales de la mairie vous voyez bien
que ceux qui ont la charge d'entretenir
la commune d'entretenir la ville pour
tous les autres
cela mérite qu'on fasse un geste pour
eux et oui si nous devons être à l'avant
garde de ce geste là nous le serons donc
c'est pas encore complètement finalisé
mais vous travailler là-dessus françois
bayrou allô oui c'est pas complètement
finalisé mais vous travailler là-dessus
françois bayrou c'est ça on travaille là
dessus avec des organisations syndicales
quand vous entendez le gouvernement qui
effectivement chaque jour annonce vous
le disiez un certain nombre de
dispositifs pour aider les entreprises
pour aider les salariés
vous avez toujours fait partie de ceux
qui disait attention il ne faut pas
creuser le déficit
il ne faut pas creuser la dette
évidemment les dans un temps
exceptionnel est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'ils aient plus de limites
qu'on puisse creuser autant qu'il le
faudra alors plus de limites je ne dis
pas sage d une chose précise c'est que
du temps où en effet j'ai fait campagne
pour mettre en garde contre le
creusement de la dette et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que si on avait plus de
marge de manoeuvre ça serait mieux comme
un certain nombre de pays qui nous
entourent mais du temps où je faisais
ces mises en garde la dette était une
dette nationale et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
extrêmement différente parce que toutes
ces dépenses qu'on doit faire toutes ces
aides qu'on doit apporter pour faire
face à l'épidémie de coronavirus
ça ça ne doit plus ça ne peut plus être
seulement une dette nationale
pourquoi le coronavirus c'est la faute
de personne il n'y a pas un pays dans le
monde dont on puisse dire c'est eux qui
ont fait des fautes de gestion dont qui
n'ont qu'à assumer la responsabilité de
leurs actes ce que je crois au contraire
c'est que cette calamité qui frappe le
monde entier qui a commencé en chine qui
est en europe qui va être demain aux
états unis en amérique du sud avec en
afrique avec les difficultés que l'on
voit cette calamité là elle doit être
assumée par l'humanité tout entière
elle doit être assumée par les
organisations politiques de l'humanité
tout entière et pour moi ça doit être
une dette partager il faut que les
banques centrales banque centrale
européenne a déjà fait un certain nombre
de choix qui sont juste la banque
centrale américaine est allée encore
plus loin il faut que les banques
centrales s'entendent pour que cette
catastrophe qui fasse l'humanité elles
soient assumées dans ses conséquences
par l'humanité t.su faut créer une
nouvelle organisation au delà des
banques centrales est ce qu'il faudrait
comme on a créé un moment l'onu imaginer
de nouvelles instances de direction pour
effectivement mettre en commun ce
fardeau
alors moi je suis pas du tout pour créer
tout le temps des organisations
supplémentaires je pense qu'il faut
mieux faire marcher les organisations
qui existent et la coopération des
banques centrales vous voyez bien que
qu'elle soit officielle ou officieuse
dans sur l'espace de la planète elle
existe en réalité entre la banque
centrale américaine et la banque
centrale européenne vous voyez qu'il y à
une réflexion partagée faute qu'elle
soit officielle elle est en tout cas
officieuse et j'espère que la banque
centrale chinoise
pour a elle aussi participé la banque
centrale japonaise à cette réflexion là
donc encore une fois c'est une
catastrophe qui frappe l'humanité toute
entière sans que nul n'en soit
responsable ou que ce soit sur la
planète
quelqu'un qui en portent la
responsabilité il faut donc l'assumer
ensemble on a envie de on a envie d'y
croire à cette forme peut-être
d'optimisme sur un fardeau partagés sur
le fait de se mettre ensemble pour y
faire face sauf que ce qu'on constate ne
serait-ce qu'à l'échelle européenne
c'est quand même un peu la loi du plus
fort ou en tout cas le chacun pour soi
chaque pays qui essaye de gagner du
temps par rapport aux autres jacques
delors est même sorti de son silence
habituel pour parler d'une menace
sérieuse le cycle climat qui règne entre
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement et
le manque de solidarité font courir un
danger mortel à l'union européenne
on est loin de ce que vous espérez d'une
forme de solidarité
ce que j'espère c'est que ils vont y
être contraint quelle que soit leur
position de départ parce que la menace
est immense vous voyez bien que si
l'europe n'a pas une réponse coordonnée
en direction de ce fardeau partager eh
bien elle explosera voyez bien que on
peut pas dire on abandonne l'italie à
son sort en abandonne l'espagne à son
sort on abandonne la france ascenseur
parce que vous allez voir que au delà
des frontières
les les mots les calamités les victimes
le nombre de personnes atteintes montre
qu' il y à une unité profonde du
continent européen
et qu'on peut pas se débarrasser de
cette unité uniquement au nom d' égoïsme
budgétaires nationaux je suis moi très
très choquée par exemple de de la
position des pays bas les pays bas ont
organisé une fiscalité pour que les
grandes entreprises aillent de
préférence se placer
leur siège européen chez eux mais on
peut pas considérer qu'à partir de là
ils sont exonérés de tout effort je
crois exactement le contraire je pense
que il faut d'une certaine manière
bloquer le compteur au début de cette
crise et analyser les dépenses qui sont
faites sur l'ensemble du continent
européen pour lutter contre cette
épidémie due coronavirus cette partie là
j'ai budget public doit être le plus
possible partagé et ceux ci et là que ce
soit presque une parenthèse est compris
dans le calcul des déficits des
différents états on n'en est plus
vraiment au calcul des déficits des
différents états je crois que cette
période là pour l'instant elle est mise
entre parenthèses et il est bon qu elle
le soit vous voyez bien que ce qui est
en cause c'est la plus grande crise
qu'on ait connu de mémoire d'homme sur
l'ensemble de la planète depuis
plusieurs siècles
parce que cette crise est là en effet un
aspect sanitaire extrêmement dangereux
mais vous voyez bien que l'économie de
la planète s'est arrêté sur sous toutes
les latitudes et dans tous les pays que
aujourd'hui 1
habitant de la terre sur deux ou presque
est confiné et ceux qui ne sont pas à
court de terribles risque
je pense à l'afrique on vient de voir
que pape diouf a été hélas le premier
mort dû coronavirus au sénégal mais vous
imaginez les risques de contagion
les risques de contagion en amérique du
sud et vous observerez que tous les
chefs d'état qui voulaient d'une
certaine manière hausser les épaules et
considérer que bon c'était pas pour eux
qu'ils allaient être plus malin que les
autres qu'ils allaient jouer avec
l'épidémie tout cela sont obligés
aujourd'hui de faire des volte face à
180° et de prendre une position
différente c'était le cas de boris
johnson c'est le cas de 30 c'est le cas
ça sera le cas de bolton arômes demain
au brésil on est obligé de considérer
que le les disciplines les efforts les
contraintes qui viennent de cette
épidémie touche l'ensemble des pays de
la planète
oui mais nous françois bayrou certes on
en a parlé très tôt mais il ya eu cette
question du maintien du premier tour des
élections
vous vous aviez tenté d'alerter emmanuel
macron et edouard philippe
en dix ans il ne faut pas tenir ce
premier temps y compris jusqu'à la
veille
vous avez tenté de faire annuler ce
premier tour des élections vous n'avez
donc finalement pas été entendu quel est
votre regret aujourd'hui par rapport à
ça bon mon regret c'est que alors même
que le président de la république était
acquis à cette idée
j'en atteste parce que j'étais à tout
instant pendant ces heures là en ligne
avec lui il fait acquis à l'idée de
reporter cette élection et puis des
responsables de l'opposition et non des
moindres et puis tout tout les toutes
les organisations politiques de
l'opposition en vérité on dit ça c'est
une ruse
c'est une atteinte à la démocratie on
veut nous empêcher de tenir les
élections c'est scandaleux on on se
prononcera contre publiquement or ce que
le président de la république avait en
tête c'était qui y ait un consensus que
toutes les forces démocratiques puissent
se dire écouter aujourd'hui c'est pas
raisonnable on va reporter un peu plus
loin les sélections c'est ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire pour des raisons
sanitaires et pour des raisons je les
dirai psychologique dans l'opinion on
peut pas à la fois fermer les bars et
les restaurants demander aux gens de ne
pas sortir de chez eux et puis maintenir
cette organisation c'est fait c'est fait
c'est derrière nous mais celui-là il ya
eu il ya eu un manque de civisme un
manque de civisme à une forme de
responsabilité de la part des
oppositions
bon je vous sentez bien que j'ai pas
envie d'être aujourd'hui dans des
polémiques internes au monde
politique française je trouve que c'est
pas bienvenus et je trouve que ceux qui
le font comment dirais-je neu neu ne
donne pas sa place à ce sentiment de co
responsabilité qui doit nous animer tous
fait pas vous
ça fait très longtemps très longtemps
que les questions que a eu à traiter le
monde politique n'était pas des
questions de vie ou de mort ça fait très
longtemps que le le sentiment que la
société peut être entraîner vers une
dissolution vers des attitudes qui sont
des attitudes de dispersion
d'antagonisme qui menace même la vie au
sens propre de nos concitoyens ces
sentiments-là de responsabilité doivent
s'imposer à tout le monde et pour moi
autant que je pourrai je ne ferai pas de
polémique mal vu
oui mais malgré tout vous rappelez quand
même qui à un moment a à freiner cette
décision cela dit d'ailleurs on peut se
dire que le président de la république
lui même à un moment aurait pu le
décider malgré les oppositions est-ce
que c'est pas ça qu'on attend aussi d'un
chef d'état dont le le le le sentiment
de la plus grande responsabilité d'un
chef d'état en tout cas je crois tels
que le président de la république leur
santé à cet instant c'était que le pays
soit uni
c'était que l'on n'aille pas à des
décisions un ordre dispersé alors pour
ma part j'étais j'avais le j'avais le
sentiment que le risque était grand mais
je comprends aussi que l'on puisse dire
on va entraîner tout le monde on va pas
on va pas se lancer dans des décisions
qui pourraient apparaître des uns contre
les autres
aujourd'hui on est donc en tout cas dans
ce dans ce confinement ce confinement
dont vous dites vous même qu'il sera
sans doute amenée à durer essayons quand
même de commencer à nous projeter vers
l'appreil à la question sanitaire et
puis la question économique
sanitairement d'abord ce confinement il
ya une question de sortie mais aussi des
modalités de sortie comment vous
imaginez la suite est-ce que du jour au
lendemain on pourra claquer dans les
doigts et repartir vers une vie comme
avant
ou est-ce qu'il faudra le faire de
manière progressive
bon d'abord c'est la question
essentielle
tout le monde voit bien que le
confinement sert à ralentir la
propagation du virus
pour des raisons qui sont des raisons
immédiates je pense par exemple la
saturation des services d'urgence des
hôpitaux et pour des raisons qui sont de
plus long terme
est ce qu'on va pouvoir avoir tous les
équipements nécessaires ce qu'on va
pouvoir avoir tous les tests nécessaires
est ce qu'on va pouvoir expérimenter des
traitements enfin tout cela est est
évidemment sont évidemment des questions
qui demandent à avoir une seule un
certain délai pour qu'on puisse les
organiser donc le confinement
c'est la mesure d'urgence la plus
importante et tous les épidémiologistes
sur toute la planète sont d'accord sur
ce sujet mais évidemment tout le monde
voit bien que ça va pas suffire à
arrêter le virus et donc ce qui est ce
qui est très important c'est que les
citoyens puissent se faire une idée nos
concitoyens de la manière dont on va
sortir du confinement
quelle sera l'étape d'après moi ce que
je crois c'est que quand on regarde ce
qui s'est fait ailleurs en corée du sud
par exemple
wakili à une mesure que dont on n'a pas
les moyens encore aujourd'hui je sais
bien parce qu'à pau nous y travaillons
tous les jours c'est une capacité de
détection généralisée qu'on puisse
lorsque le moment viendra de lever le
confinement qu'on ait les moyens de voir
qui a été atteint par le virus qui est
porteur du virus dans le moment présent
et qui n'a pas été atteint il se trouve
que les tests que nous avons aujourd'hui
sans vouloir faire de de précision
technique mais les tests que nous avons
aujourd'hui sont des tests qui mesure la
présence du virus au moment où on fait
le prélèvement
mais il ya d'autre systèmes de détection
qu'on appelle sérologique et qui regarde
dans le sang la trace de la
contamination du vélo récentes ou très
antérieur le fait de l'avoir eu parce
que en principe jeudi en principe parce
que les débats médicaux que vous savez
sont très importants en principe lorsque
on a rencontré le virus
on est vaccinés d'une certaine manière
et donc on est à l'abri d'une
recontamination sam est un cas
extrêmement vous seriez vous seriez
favorable idéalement à un test quasi
généralisée pour pouvoir vérifier
effectivement qu'on a les anticorps
qu'on l'a bien eu
mais vous le disiez vous même vous
disiez dont on n'a pas les moyens
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas tout le
problème malgré tout on découvre alors
vous le disiez il faut pas faire de
polémique évidemment c'est pas le moment
mais il ya quand même un petit
découragement quand on a le sentiment
que parfois les masques on nous a dit
c'est pas utile mais on se rend compte
que c'était aussi parce qu'on n'en avait
pas les tests on nous a dit c'est pas
forcément utile de les généraliser mais
c'est aussi parce qu'on en avait pas est
ce que on aura les moyens à temps pour
pouvoir sortir de cette crise avec des
tests généralisée comme vous l'évoquez
alors il ya deux questions dont votre
question la première c est ce qu on a
est ce qu'on aura les moyens de cette
détection là je crois que oui
d'après ce que disent les industriels et
à la fois ceux qui produisent les
machines qui font les tester ce qu'ils
produisent les réactifs chimiques
oui je crois qu'on aura à court terme ou
à moyen court terme les moyens de faire
des détections très large il ya des
appareils des machines notamment pour
les tests sérologiques qui permettront
de traiter plusieurs centaines de
milliers peut-être davantage encore de
test par semaine bien et après tout il
ya des pays qui ont qui ont fait cela
donc je crois que techniquement on
pourra et les pouvoirs publics feront
l'effort nécessaire je n'ai aucun doute
il ya une deuxième question c'est est ce
qu'il a été prudent dans la période
passée de se défaire de se démunir de
nos capacités de production de
production de médicaments j'entendais
tout à l'heure l'appel des responsables
des hôpitaux et notamment des hôpitaux
de paris sur le fait qu' il craignait de
manquer des médicaments nécessaires
notamment pour les anesthésies du curare
par exemple et donc de ce point de vue
là ce que ça a été prudent de se démunir
y compris de la fabrication des masques
et le président de la république a
répondu hier je fais j'ai le même
sentiment que le sien ça a été très
imprudent vous souvenez que j'ai fait
des campagne présidentielle sur le thème
de produire en france produire en europe
parce que ce qui est de l'ordre de 2,2
l'essentiel pour l'indépendance d'un
pays ce qui concerne sa santé ce qui
concerne sa défense
alors il faut à tout prix qu'on le
conserve sur le sol je dis pas seulement
du pays mais de notre union européenne
au moins de l'union européenne étroite
ceux qui décident ce qu'ils ont l'air
ceux qui ont la volonté et au fond c'est
ce que jacques delors rappelait d'aller
de l'avant ensemble et donc
l'indépendance sur l'indépendance il
faudra un avant et un après parce que je
ne crois pas une seconde que la société
repartira après une crise sanitaire
économique social démocratique peut-être
de cet ordre là je crois pas qu'on va
repartir comme avant par exemple je ne
crois pas que la manière de vivre
ensemble de se saluer sera la même
qu'avant beaucoup de choses vont changer
et d'une certaine manière il ya
peut-être aussi un espoir dans le fait
que tant de choses vont changer dans la
société
on restera sur ce mot là le mot d'espoir
on en a tous envie et on en a tous
besoin à ce moment
merci françois bayrou d'avoir été avec
moins directe de poche